kamal taha bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
assiste à une large victoire de roch
kaboré l'opposition qui a pris acte
justement de ce résultat kaboré qui veut
aujourd'hui apaisé les esprits mais
aussi faire face à la menace terroriste
est ce que vous pensez qu'il va tendre
la main justement à l'opposition pour
unifier et apporter la paix au burkina
faso oui je crois qu'il était
tempérament de marc christian kaboré et
des burkinabè de façon générale de temps
de la mède un pays apaisé dans lequel le
dialogue est généralement culture du
pays
non je n'ai pas de souci de ce point de
vue là la difficulté pour lui ne se
posera évidemment pas au niveau du
dialogue dans dans son pays ça ils
iraient ils arrivent à tout cas tant de
la mer parce que c'est encore une fois
comme je les vis son tempérament la
question s'il demande au lieu de deux
étages la divinité c'est qu'il a un pays
qui fait face à une situation
sécuritaire très grave à laquelle il lui
même de toute façon seule ne peut pas
apporter une réponse
la réponse est forcément régional et le
dépasse deuxièmement c'est qu'il a un
défi majeur c'est de pouvoir construire
une armée faible émiettez qui
malheureusement ces dernières années n'a
pas été capable de faire face à la
menace terroriste
le deuxième étage de la réflexion qui va
lui être posées vrai problème c'est
l'astuce et l'économique
à quelle il faut faire face de toute
façon n'oublions pas que dans ce pays
lors de cette élection près de 300
milles 3 400 mille personnes n'ont pas
pu voter dans le nord à cause de la
situation sécuritaire de la population
du nord les populations du nord de façon
générale ne sont pas très contents de la
situation
latifi des difficultés qu'a qui lui fera
face est aussi difficultés économiques
cette croissance burkinabè je sais
qu'elle est 10 6%
enfin vous voyez vous ce qu'en sens
africain est toujours très généreuse
elle ne crée pas d'emplois elle la
pauvre elle elle ne sent pas les gens de
la pauvreté
le burkinabè le burkina mâles rejoints
n'échappe pas à cette situation
le deuxième problème tâche de la
difficulté c'est le co vide 19 quitte
les problèmes de cit et de crise
économique majeure les frontières forme
et fermer la relation des pays étrangers
ton totalement inexistante dans un pays
totalement enclavé qui n'ont d'autre
choix que de voir une relation avec les
pays extérieurs
et puis l'enjeu qui va être pour lui
centrale encore une fois je disais
talent c'est de construire une armée une
vraie armée là il a gagné une élection
et tant mieux pour lui avait pas
tellement notre
ils on savait très bien qu'il allait
gagner l'enseignement nouveau c'est que
désormais il à l'embryon d'une
opposition à laquelle il s'attendait pas
c'est le cdp le résultat dédié compagnie
go il ne faut évidemment pas le
sous-estimer c'est probablement le
prémice d'une nouvelle opposition enfin
vous durée et la demande arrivé en sont
deuxièmes cependant terminé mais l'enjeu
pollue va être absolument colossal il a
pendant sa campagne
kaboré promis un forum de réconciliation
nationale qui devrait avoir lieu au
premier trimestre de l'année prochaine
est ce que vous pensez que voilà ce
forum de réconciliation nationale peut
permettre à calmer un peu les esprits
pour repartir de l'avant
sûrement mais ce qui va calmer les
esprits vraiment c'est la situation
économique et la situation sécuritaire
kill kill kill qu'il puisse apaiser une
situation politique aujourd'hui
totalement maîtrisé pour lui par un
score qui est plutôt un spectable c'est
qu'un but pour ça il n'y a pas de doute
là dessus
vous voyez vous il en deuxième surnom
des burkinabè qui ne manque pas d'humour
l'appelle monsieur diesel parce qu'il a
une difficulté réelle à pouvoir démarrer
le problème c'est que amanda ces cinq
ans et donc les cinq années qui viennent
de s'écouler dans lesquelles il a
démarré de façon assez lente
d'où son nom surnom de cy diesel plutôt
mériter la difficulté qu'il aura
maintenant c'est patent de rassuré
provisoirement ses opposants les vallées
rassurer mes ouvriers ou les opposants
qu'on pouvait les rassuré provisoirement
enfin tant que la situation pour vous
est favorable y vont ils voient
tranquille si la situation n'est les
mois ils le seront moi c'est l'enjeu
fondamental qui va être pour lui
déterminant c'est la situation
sécuritaire et la situation économique
ce sont deux facteurs le burkina
aujourd'hui qui sont dramatiques
n'oublions absolument pas de ce pays vit
une crise économique majeure
la santé la gravité de la santé est
réelle urgence alimentaire est
absolument réelle qu est la divinité
sécuritaire ne permet naturellement pas
d'entrevoir une solution agents parce
qu'encore une fois elle ne dépend pas
que de lui l régionales elles les
dépassent c'est à dire qu'il est dans un
dans un dans un carrefour très compliqué
dans lequel il ya des pays qui depuis
très longtemps font face à une sécurité
compliquée à laquelle il ya les jeux pan
de même pas tellement mieux que lui mais
lui encore moins parce que il a connu
une transition compliquée il
mais totalement éclatés emile était
faible à reconstruire
et puis ajoutez à tout ça c'est un pays
enclavé dans laquelle la situation
sécuritaire mondial depuis une année
n'arrange pas la situation
je ne suis pas en train de dresser un
tableau apocalyptique pour lui et je
fais confiance a encore une fois la
capacité des burkinabè de se mettre
autour d'une table et négocier et de
discuter sans doute d'arriver à parvenir
à une solution probablement qui peuvent
satisfaire la difficulté va l'aider
passé l'association de ces critères les
dépasse la crise économique les dépasse
la président à vie de 10,9 le dépasse et
l'enclavement des pays n'arrange pas la
situation mais espérons souhaitant que
tout ce que le président kaboré compte
mettre en oeuvre réussissent c'est en
tout cas tout le mal que je leur
souhaite
merci beaucoup en tout cas j'aimerais
taleb d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat et vice
président de l'observatoire du
développement africain